this episode brought to you by the
Dollar Shave Club a great shave at a
great price conveniently delivered right
to your home
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember so you don't have to imagine
Deadpool Andy Kaufman and Monty Python's
Flying Circus made a Saturday morning
cartoon a superhero who saw
crime-fighting as a side thing
especially when there's more important
things to do like teach Norwegian this
is the narwhal Doudna ern north wall
perform a wedding for your hands or
figure out which monkeys in the movie
Congo were actually monkeys and which
ones were guys in suits that's our real
monkey no that's some guy in a suit okay
but now that's a real monkey no that's
another guy in a suit now that's a real
monkey
we're gonna have to see this again oh
and remember when your mom wished you a
good time at the prom what if that just
repeated through the course of the night
over and over and over have a good time
now you may think this kind of animated
in sandy came from something like Family
Guy or Adult Swim or any number of
YouTube videos but the fact is this
combination of animation and troll humor
predates them all it's the 90s kinda ish
hit freakazoid
produced by Steven Spielberg this was a
very different beast compared to his
other productions like Tiny Toons or
Animaniacs I know we never got as big as
those shows it grew a cult following
over the years well this type of
self-aware almost non humor at times has
been done in the past you could argue
it's never been done in animation on as
big a scale as this now animated shows
of this kind of humor everywhere but in
the 90s there wasn't really anything
quite like this shows have knocked down
the fourth wall in the past but this
show walked past the wall chanted with
the people on the air side observe the
snacks on the catering table and discuss
those snacks in the history of them in
great detail whether they're you know
religious experience all or not I love
them all of them will hug after the show
to some this could be off-putting what
did the select number of crazies and
wackos that love this kind of non
sequitur humor this was just the right
amount of madness its energy contagious
its maturity obliterated its lasting
facts completely unique and I'm here to
talk with the people who made this
possible ladies and gentlemen for the
first time ever on this Township critic
I give you co creator Tom Ruger and
freakazoid himself oh oh we've been on
the show before
what what Animaniacs tribute oh shit
yeah yeah well this is the first time
you're on the show talking about
freakazoid right I guess
okay okay I'll just build up that angle
cool for the very first time on this -
you tried to talk freakazoid - Tom
Winger
[Applause]
first of all thank you for coming on my
show just to come on my show and not
promote some sort of product or event
no problem critic we're just happy to
chat with you about anything so the show
was originally being developed by Batman
producer Bruce Timm as well as Paul Dini
who was tasked with making a superhero
comedy he dropped some characters and
even tested a sort of demo with the
Batman episode beware the creeper mixing
comedy in action Bruce Timm his
specialty was superhero stuff steven
basically wanted a comedy show where
Bruce wanted a superhero show with
comedic overtones I think Steven was
really trying to push it to be very very
very comedic first and that's just not
something I mean Bruce Timm was
interested in doing as far as the
silliness pretty much hit it out of the
park it may have gone even sillier than
Steven had anticipated I would say
that's probably true I wanted to do one
of those funny things like any ever
watch F Troop or Agarn says there's no
way I'm wearing a dress before
strucker's like yeah you were in that
dress and then they wipe and Aaron's
wearing a dress
seeing how time and budget were already
low everybody came running in to freaka
so he with little time to prepare and
even less time to figure out what kind
of show was going to be even in several
episodes they confess they don't always
know what they want to keep around my
freakalair I didn't know you had one of
these well in this episode anyway you
know we're trying a lot of stuff out we
started in January developing the show
and writing up stuff and we were gonna
be honest of temper so we've had 8 9
months as opposed to say like Animaniacs
where we had like two years yes right
yes the show was gonna be Greenland we
were on and we we didn't have anything
we didn't have a show we didn't really
know who was in it and we knew there's a
guy named freakazoid in it that's all we
knew we just started writing anything we
could think of that had a superhero in
it and was funny that's why some of the
early segments are just little strange
little pieces like legends who lunch or
hand
handman you've come in the nick of time
I wouldn't let you down freaky bizarre
oh just stop what this is stupid
part of what makes the humor work is
Bruce Tim's designs having a more human
look and scale then less stretchy than
say Wakko Warner or plucky duck the fact
that they're more physically grounded
offsets the strange and childish humor
they're constantly partaking him if say
Ren and Stimpy were doing this material
it would have worked as well but much
like Monty Python the more human and
adult they seem the funnier it is when
they do something strange and ridiculous
what's this always the intention can
only say yes yes unlike other superhero
shows even comedies freakazoid started
off more as a variety show it showcased
many strange characters like Lord
bravery the Huntsman and fanboy did
absolutely nothing superhero related in
any episodes don't get me wrong they
tried to get to the superhero stuff but
the slow forces of reality always
prolonged it to a point where we never
actually see any of it oh yes let me get
the tea you forgot to show that most
people your age die why won't you and
shows like the tick reality would get in
the way too but he did eventually fight
crime here it's a complete waste of time
every episode what can I say huntsman
crime is still down maybe I'll go to the
all-night aquarium when we were given
the go-ahead to start working on the
show we have to just start generating
material writing stupid little things
about superheroes I had about 60 to 70
pages of just little little tiny skits
Stephen I think he liked them but
thought they
like schizophrenic a hey one of the
early sketches I did was a moron which I
think insulted Stephen right off the bat
let's bury that well that's our show I
hope you had as much fun watching it as
we had making it come to think of it I
hope you had more fun watching it than
we had making it Paul of course came up
with which was also essential an origin
story which I think was like the fifth
or sixth episode to air John McCann and
I we were sort of being more practical
like how does freakazoid turn into
freakazoid and days think thinking about
that and we came back into Tom and said
we think we know how he turns into
freakazoid and I think you said I could
care less where Murray we're really late
so I need some scripts I don't care how
it could change from week to week I
don't care but he also figured out how
one of his superpowers was flying which
was just him running around going go
even the origin of freakazoid isn't
revealed until episode 7 but maybe that
so they would have time to obtain their
knockout celebrity guest the president
of the Motion Picture Association of
America mr. Jack Valenti holy shit they
know what the kids want bum bum bum the
origin story came about because I think
halfway through the season Tom had a
brilliant idea it's like what why don't
we tackle how this all happened
you spend far too much time with your
computer it's my life that's so very
very sad I was playing around and I
started writing Jack Valenti who was the
president of the Motion Picture
Association of America just as a joke
the only note we got back on that whole
episode was Stephen said I can get you
jack and were like man I'd like to know
how freakazoid got his start as a
superhero what were the special
circumstances my home is made of Adobe I
think that was one of the favorite
things that whoever did cuz here's this
guy he was in the Johnson administration
that was the reason I'm doing this and I
tell you when he comes into room the
first thing you see are the cheeks yeah
I'm Jack Valenti and these are my cheeks
god bless the gift stars on the show
often have articulate commanding almost
Shakespearean voices that have done a
wide range of theatre and film the
demanding presence just makes the humor
all the more enjoyable when you realize
how much their talent is being
hilariously wasted on pure immaturity
now look at this dark it's just a doll
y'all my friend it's a plain old dark no
it's a very special duck because there
is a guy on it well we did have some
great guest stars I think there were
certain things that Paul wanted to hear
from it Ricardo saying you are the
weenie
I remember Peter Hastings running into
my office and going you're gonna have
Ricardo maman say uncle Fletcher's
cooking lab and I got ya and he goes if
they didn't have to pay me anymore just
to have them say that was awesome
this man is giving his wife kissing's
and loving his penny monkey appears and
she thinks it's the guy look out more
Mon it's a monkey my personal favorites
are David Warner is the lobe whose voice
is so intimidating ways being evil the
lobe began his tricks on us reign of
terror on yet so funny ways being a
whiny crybaby no now that wasn't me it's
true really I knew I shouldn't have put
that on that dum dum dum and of course
that as nerds cosgrove whose deadpan
deliveries of absolute insanity are an
art unto themselves we've been through a
lot together
now go away that means we'll have to
walk through duty water I always liked
the little teacup ride how come you
never got married because I like meat
too much you could be married and still
eat a lot of meat I didn't know that
cosgrove is sort of an invention from
John McCain he only put him in one
script his dance of dune script so the
first time Ed Asner came to record he
was sort of like just there by the
microphone just reading over his lines
not not even acting going hey freakazoid
you want to go for a mint and I remember
it John McCain went that is what I want
and he's like you don't want me to do
anything Iraq and jump it guys like know
that it would come in and go ahead don't
worry you don't have to act and he'd go
yeah and that's how that happened it
might also have believe it or not the
most insane Tim Curry performance ever
it's turbulent to track and if you know
Tim Curry that is quite an
accomplishment they bowed me from the
universities who's crazy now
fried the casserole Tim Curry came ready
to play I was always amazed because
Andrei Romano would send out the scripts
and they would have him for a week and
invariably every single big star we had
they came ready
so obviously Tim Curry had thought about
how he was gonna do all that they called
me mad insane Windom and he just went
like through the roof and were like they
called me mad and Shane Wendel there was
a camera crew there to film Cancri being
there and Jonathan Harris blocked in
John is like is that camera crew because
of stars
we're Tiny Toon seemed mainly for kids
and Animaniacs he mainly for kids and
adults
freakazoid seemed mainly not just for
adults but for adults who loved obscure
even outdated references Christ there's
a musical sent up to Hello Dolly for no
reason at all and it goes on for a long
time bozo you have to wonder if this
worked more because it was a kids show
and therefore fit and less or if being
on a more grown-up outlet like Adult
Swim would have changed things we were
trying to amuse ourselves make each
other laugh and that was our goal I
don't think we ever said can we get away
with that it was the thought was I find
this really funny what do you guys think
oh yeah I think that's really funny and
that was always the goal it wasn't to
pull the wool over anyone's eyes or
truly we weren't trying to slip
something pass yeah as far as Hello
Dolly the Hello Dolly number that just
seemed the natural progression for
whatever reason I thought it'd be funny
to have sort of a Hello Dolly component
to it never thought oh boy
our kids are not gonna
hello thought we didn't really care
which clearly shows because the number
goes on for five minutes I think it took
like seven months to just animate that's
the man that's weird stuff with that
said did anyone ever say no like anyone
we weren't being closely supervised the
goal was to do it the thing don't get it
out there the only thing I recall where
they said no you can't run these we make
these cruise ship commercials
based on a cruise line they were very
somber you can relax
cruise ships everything is nice so we
did these commercials work we don't have
any footage to show you from freakazoid
because brewing behind schedule and but
we had cruise ship but it's pictures of
Bruce ships behind it but the lawyers
that Warner Brothers said no these are
too close to the real commercial you
can't we'll get sued one of you at some
point must have just dated no this is
too obscure too silly too crazy no we
would only say no to each other like
yeah that's not funny or only think
that's gonna fly I remember John McCann
and I we struggle a bit with here oh boy
like bringing him back and stuff but
then we were like I'll is let's just
let's just do more here oh boy so but I
spider on the counter voiced by John
McCann and muscle team I'm I succeed I
must succeed I must succeed I must
succeed poor nose I wouldn't know
anything about obscurity of course
everybody gets that
[Applause]
[Music]
you
hey guys you want the shit shower and
shave starter set cuz that's what I get
to sell you today I'm not even kidding
from the Dollar Shave Club it's the shit
shower and shave starter set but it
doesn't just out there I get to sell you
one wipe Charlies butt wipes yes this is
actually what they're called can we just
take a moment and appreciate how life
has led me to a point where I get to
sell you shit shower and shave starter
set with one wipe Charlies butt wipes
okay as you can tell I'm a guy who
shaves his head a lot so I need really
good razors in Dallas shave club that
only has really good razors but they
mail them right to your door they're so
sharp so smooth and on top of that they
sell a bunch of other shower stuff
that's a lie you probably have I've gone
to the store a lot to get these really
cheap razors or you got to kind of shop
around to find the good one and you
don't want to have to do them and you
don't want to have to scrape up your
head or your face to find a really good
one these are good as you can tell they
have a really good sense of humor and
for a limited time dollar shave club is
basically giving away their shit shower
and shave starter set to new members for
only $5 the starter set features their
executive razor and three trial size
versions of the most popular products
that can help you stay fresh and clean
in your first box you'll receive their
shave butter another great name body
wash and yes one white Charlie's butt
wipes you'll also receive their
executive razor which includes the
premium wavy handle and full cassette of
cartridges and after the first box
replacement cartridges are sent for only
a few bucks a month for razors this good
that really is a steal this offer is
exclusively available at the link in the
description dollarshaveclub.com slash
awesome and on top of em when you buy
their stuff it enables them to support
our channel and I get to sell you one
white chocolate but life is good they
have a lot more than just great razors
they have really great products with
really great names give them a try and
you too can look like Lex Luthor Athene
never moved out of his parents basement
go to the dalvik shave club comm slash
awesome and test out your one wipe
Charlies but it
yeah I can't just go
[Music]
[Applause]
in season two the format changed
slightly to focus more on freakazoid
imagine focusing on the start of the
show characters like Lord bravery and
the Huntsman asked what the hell
happened to their role
freakazoid has them wash his car and the
episode ends if it's the show's nature
of course but was it tough losing those
characters and changing the format our
second season you went off to do Rovers
regular John I were like well who will
produce it we don't want to do that do
you McCready took us to lunch and she
said I really need you to do this and
I'm holding a knife under the table
we're like okay we'll do it we had a
meeting at emmalin i think with Jamie
Kellner and all the big one of others
mucky-mucks and they all decided that we
should not do any more silly little
pieces but half our stories but little
did they know we would just be like
we'll just do longer stupid things I
didn't mind it so much I think it opened
me up anyway to do weirder stuff but
that's just me oh he had more time to do
yeah their stuff sadly though the
audience for freakazoid was not growing
as big as the studio wanted every time a
new timeslot was given it would move
around the following week 7:00 a.m. it's
not the time the people who want to
watch this show are off well I think the
constantly changing air times
sort of killed us on the WB the WB had
this new campaign big kids go first
so they were still on at 7:00 a.m. a big
kids were asleep then we ultimately get
bounced over to Cartoon Network we had
incredibly great numbers and there was
talk of them ordering more episodes in
the final episode most of the villains
allies and guest stars are all called
back to seeing we'll meet again
was there an awareness that this will
probably be the final episode they knew
yeah and
new WB hated us like a lot when I was
writing that last episode we knew we
were cancelled and when I finally
started writing we'll meet again all
that stuff I was like man this is this
is this is kind kind of sad and by the
way I think that was one of the only
musical pieces we ever licensed and it
cost a fortune
gene mccurdy had seen norm Abram at some
convention in New York and she came back
and I saw her in the office she said oh
I saw norm Abram like a boy he'd be
great guy to have on freakazoid and I
was kind of joking and she said well I
can get him he took acting classes for
like six months
yes preparation for the show yes but
maybe it's not the end of freakazoid as
we know it what's freaking kott
frequency up you Larry sort of is on the
upswing people want to talk about it a
lot our idea was to sort of bring
convention together and we talked you
know we talked with various people we
looked into Radio City Music Hall
could we you know could we make a deal
there and we couldn't quite come to
terms then we tried you know Staples
Center Los Angeles couldn't quite almost
almost couldn't quite making them so but
then we we finally have a new venue
um and it's Tom's garage it's an
intimate space kind of answer questions
for the first time live have people
write questions and we'll answer it Paul
Dean's gonna be there Paul Paul Dini we
have Joe Leahy coming we have Steve and
Julie Bernstein coming who are going to
be sharing their musical gifts there is
a contest out there for people to
reinvent their idea of freakazoid fanboy
or fangirl make a video of them saying
why freakazoid is probably the best
superhero ever and dressed up as their
fan ID right so we want to get as many
people tuning in to this live event on
March 15 5:00 p.m. Pacific time go to
the Facebook page and writing questions
that will be
well if you're a freakazoid fan that is
definitely worth checking out
freakazoid is strange crazy and doesn't
apologize for any of it it's the kind of
humour done by people who half the time
don't even care if you find it funny as
long as they find it funny that kind of
love and dedication for your own jokes
is both so odd and yet so passionate you
can't help but find it intriguing
freakazoid is certainly not everybody's
show but in a kids market that tries to
get as many demographics as possible
that truly does make it unique it
doesn't satirise what's popular it
satirizes what it loves it doesn't get
mega stars you know it gets fun people
they've always wanted to work with it's
not Tiny Toons Animaniacs or Pinky and
the brain
it's its own totally abstract creature
it's insane it's weird it has to be seen
to totally get it or not get it it's one
of a kind and a lot of people worked
hard to make it that way thank you guys
so much again for talking to me about
this crazy Asha thank you know you you
mm-hmm
doesn't want to eat yup have a good time
now I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember
so you don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you could be married and still eat a lot
of meat I didn't know that
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing
care org care is a global leader within
a worldwide movement dedicated to ending
poverty they are known everywhere for
their unshakable commitment to the
dignity of people they work around the
globe to save lives and defeat poverty
seeking a world of hope and tolerance
where poverty has been overcome and all
people live with dignity and security
their core values commitment reflects
what they focus on transformation
integrity diversity excellence and
equality if you look at their site in
their YouTube channel you can see all
the various creative ways they try to
help so many people in so many different
places they have a dedication that is
unrivaled and you can help in continuing
their mission click on the link below
and see how many people you can help
around the world
[Music]
you